[Music]
in trigger warning needed news sue
submitted by father yes fan love you yes
Daddy yes
fatiah the Mexican last name I failed
Spanish for time so I can get that
stupid role on my side
sounds like a woman's fart fatty yes
sorry yes sony has apologized for an
allergy scene in the new Peter Rabbit
movie after backlash from parents an
allergy see Peter Rabbit is a cute
little toy right it's based on a book
it's a rabbit right it sounds so
familiar at foreign at the same time is
it the rabbit with the overall I don't
because I know Bunnicula hmm Bunnicula
was that bunny that was a vampire I just
remember Velveteen Rabbit and being
[ __ ] sad as hell as a kid look a
Bunnicula right now you guys have missed
out did you have a trigger warning for
[ __ ] Velveteen Rabbit that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] burn it all my [ __ ] toys and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and in the kid dies it was
cuz of Bui bubonic plague or some [ __ ]
oh really
I remember I think Bunnicula was a thing
Oh baby's mom dad dude I was like oh
[ __ ] there is like spoiler alert
sorry images it's a bunny vampire Oh
Bunnicula I've never seen this in my
life might be like a horror [ __ ] fine
my childhood is becoming really funny
right now it's like something that was
very much cemented is now not the same
oh is it like bunny Dracula yeah bunny
are you kidding me you stop this for
that [ __ ]
no I'm saying this is like a childhood
thing that everybody knows no wait
that's not Bunnicula is it no it says
Bunnicula no but maybe let's wait hold
on a second no but that's not the right
particular that's two currents okay okay
back out there that uh oh gee Bunnicula
fans you know stand up can you guys
please help me out here hope we didn't
misrepresent all you oh gee Bunnicula
fans out there
Jesus well what's happening in the movie
no [ __ ] that let's go
back to Bnei Noach oh this is the
original Peter Rabbit it's like your
jacket I knew it I get yeah I don't
remember it though I knew this guy he's
from a very popular children's book
not more than Bunnicula but more popular
because at least we've heard of Peter
Rabbit
well alright fine whatever [ __ ] it I'm
still let it go Hey look no Bunnicula
Pan's fans parents are pissed off about
anything right they're pissed that an
Insane Clown Posse isn't touring anymore
yeah so now there is a movie coming out
of Peter Rabbit all right it's already
out actually Peter Rabbit movies already
out and I'll show you guys the a quick
trailer so you guys can be on the same
page here I love trailers karate
[Music]
[Music]
from the French I want to watch it
really cute it makes me not want to
watch it Labatt's for me it's like
always cast classically trained actors
yeah because like guys who with the
[ __ ] Julliard you not I mean and
that's like and then he has to stand
there and pretend that he's getting nut
shot at by a [ __ ] rap you spent like
the last 15 years of theater do I do I
want to hear this guy get interviewed by
James let me say tell me about Peter
Rabbit he's like where are we you and
you're learning to do the they wanted to
do like shape drill Aguirre smoke very
long cigarette as well right make sure
they get that cat Daniel Stern like Joe
Pesci all these guys we've got nut shot
at the movies like doing nut shot
roundtable of like getting that shot at
a movie there should be an Oscar Award
that's not stuff of the year I'd watch
the Oxford annotated yeah they'll be
though I try to remember all like the
childhood stories or the books that I've
know maybe you should stop Bunnicula but
what else is there besides Peter Rabbit
there's a few other Winnie the Pooh is
Winnie the Pooh Christopher Robin hungry
caterpillar that was my [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] is that goes that one has a red
face in a green and that food ate
everything up and turn into a butterfly
well at the end of the book this guy we
would we would have snacks I'm gonna
corroborate with that because nobody
knows Bunnicula
yes amazing [ __ ] sweetie yeah right a
t-shirt home here's one of my favorite
books because at the end of the book the
teacher would have a bunch of different
snacks and we would eat those snacks oh
this is where we can stick your finger
through the thing yeah
alright I'm still lost but you stick
your finger through the thing and
there's like a little bit of fabric and
it's like the original book is like made
out of cardboard it's like thick ass
babe like that so I happen with the
allergies industry as you can see in the
trailer it's the rabbits against the
character named Tom in the movie and so
a pair
one of the scenes Tom is allergic to
blackberries and Peter uses this to his
advantage to get access to his garden
and so what he does is he pelts him with
fruits and veggies before using a
slingshot to send a blackberry into the
man's mouth and then he started going
into an anaphylactic shock over the
point where he was trying to get his
EpiPen in the movie right in the movie
yeah I know that's pretty dark when you
but when you say it out loud and tips
boys
it sounds dark but when you watch the
movie it's like it's like they're
playing that [ __ ] big song to it
exactly right hey Peter rabbits like
good short bait and [ __ ] I think the
fact that they probably introduced the
EpiPen is kind of a right but tips
talking about it like you know the guy
got murdered the next day and like the
actors dead
she wasn't with the dark like British
accent too he released his EpiPen from
his right pocket stabbed it into his
left thigh yeah in seconds of collapsing
in the memory and foaming out the mouth
and and it made a silly noise when he
fell down I know yeah and so now parents
are boycotting this movie oh my god why
cuz they're saying that this movie
should have your trigger warning it
should be rated R but it is before after
the kids are playing grads I thought oh
that's the question boysenberry
poisoning like a big thing out there or
like what is it blackberry cuz you know
how like peanuts is [ __ ] nuts out
here good they are nuts all right
apparently for these for these parents
the issue here is the fact that they're
taking allergies like lightly and that
it's funny to use someone it's a [ __ ]
fictional movie I mean look at home
alone [ __ ] the main character imagine
coming out today that'd be horrible you
want kid home what kind of irresponsible
parents are you what are you teaching
parent of kids that they can use well
the household items to make weapon is
yeah this is why we need more home loans
to that Oh God that's a sad
there's this one parent saying how she
took her her kids to go see this movie
her in the movie the kid pointed out
himself according to mom saying like you
know we'll really bothered me with that
scene with the BlackBerry don't talking
to the movie kid you know it also sucks
the guys trying to murder [ __ ]
rabbits with a rake yeah what about that
hey what I'm talking about and also to
the [ __ ] I mean obviously this kid has
no friends so what's going on there
let's talk about the home let's talk
about the issues that right now why you
watch the movie I mean are these kids
like Bubble Boy and [ __ ] like are they
are they that out I think the u.s. kids
aren't like that because when we went
out to Australia remember that kids like
playset and stuff the public park oh
yeah yeah it was like this huge like
12-foot like Half Dome thing where kids
had zero safety net they were swinging
having a really good time and like I'm
having to the top of it's like two or
three stories high
in America parents would freak the [ __ ]
out do you play why the [ __ ] our kids so
high up there but it's like you play on
your own risk and in Australia I think I
want has more common sense if the kid
wants to climb up there they know the
risk if they fall down they father you
know what's terrible like I think as a
parent like I'll say I watched and I
brought my kid there he took me outside
he goes hey Dad you know honestly when
they made fun of the guy with the
allergies I was really disturbed I was
like well sudden put this doll in your
pocket walk outside cuz I'm gonna rob
you little [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't ever say that [ __ ]
to me again so we I was in like a family
you know we were family Tex chains or
whatever yeah so the other day my
brother we were all in a family texting
and me and my dad were asking my brother
a question about like I can't remember
what the [ __ ] it was right it was no big
nothing and my brother he wrote back
he's like wow like you guys you don't
even have to like you don't have to jump
down my freaking throat about this thing
or whatever and I was like I wish you
could hear the the ghost of my
grandfather like reading you saying this
text right now because he would call you
a little [ __ ] [ __ ] like like why
look what goes through your head as a
grown man who was in the military to say
like hey guys no need to jump down my
throat I can't [ __ ] believe that he
set that [ __ ] you don't sound like I'm
just like but the pacification of of the
world that we're in is just absolutely
everywhere it's at what age do you think
the fragile [ __ ] should like start
changing and becoming an adult for you
know like 13 2 to 3 years old they can
still be a fragile [ __ ] because they
are right so then like I don't know
maybe around 5 or 6 around that age you
got to start teaching them I don't know
I also feel like it's the parents though
like this mom is going we need trigger
warnings instead of love what happened
is the kid is letting the mom how
affected he is and instead the mom using
that chance to guide him and write her
and empower him she is now complaining
the other way so it's being a sensitive
as [ __ ] I think so the parents but it's
like when I [ __ ] up in my friend's
house and if I spill in their floor and
then they're there they got mad at me
and I go home and I tell my mom hey I
spilled their floor but they don't they
totally freaked out at me and then my
mom goes over there and she's like why
did you freak out of my son see my mom
would have been like why did you spill
[ __ ] on their [ __ ] that's my mom yeah
she would have beat my ass she would
have been like you're embarrassing me
but that's not how it is now it's like I
tell my I care thing and you don't tell
him I can't think this is job never
backing up my kid ever
same Bart so she was saying like she did
use that opportunity to talk to her kid
and stuff but she was just saying like
for the other parents like other parents
should have a trigger warning so then
they can speak to their kids about like
kids I actually go through this on the
daily basis where they have serious
life-threatening allergies yeah no [ __ ]
that may not exist in the world she was
just saying like you know it would be
nice if Sony would have provided a
trigger warning so then we could talk to
her yeah it's the rating so it's GP or
the fact that there was like an allergy
joke in there oh that's life you [ __ ]
you know I make jokes there's gonna be
in a comedy we watch this movie and when
we got home my son trying to communicate
with his rabbit and his rabbit would not
talk back and I wish that Sony would
have communicated to us that rabbits
cannot communicate ridiculous it's
[ __ ] stupid dude I don't give a [ __ ]
that's why burn it all down let's say
except be it the kids now man just [ __ ]
it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]